alright time once again for the movie
retrospective doing a really
underappreciated one on this show
this is Exorcist 3 I can't believe I've
never seen this movie otherwise known as
Legion I can't believe it either
no man I love the Exorcist one and then
I saw extras just two guys kind of
laughed at it yeah it's kind of Exorcist
ooh is pretty Universal revivals goofy
so super dumb I get I just totally
ignored all the other exorcists after
that this is a good one man this is by
the same director right same writer as
the first one yeah not the same director
William Friedkin didn't do it but it
ain't got William Peter Blatty who wrote
the original novel yes yeah this novel
and he directed it the tone and
everything is just like the first one
this is very yeah there should be no
Exorcist
- it should only be exercised not and
three this movie acted like there was no
it made no reference at all to exorcise
I can't believe I didn't see this is a
[ __ ] great movie it's a great short
see Scott yeah damn that if you gotta
put Scott in a movie that [ __ ] is gonna
act he definitely does he does that
[ __ ] scenery man he acted through the
whole thing that everybody was acting
yeah everybody was at and they were
acting okay they were serious about it
acting yeah they were acting now they
were you know but I liked it the [ __ ]
town was perfect at a second it was a
great response to the first mission this
should have never been called Exorcist 3
it should have never it should have been
called Legion well yet the original one
that's ok well what ended up happening
this movie came out in 1990 um like I
said after Exorcist - The Heretic came
out which to have Linda Blair and stuff
like that in it um pretty universally
panned you know it did really shitty at
the box office and everything so I feel
like um William Peter Blatty who wrote
the original novel he was not
particularly interested in doing a
sequel to The Exorcist
but then he kind of got the idea of
doing he's like well why don't I do a
book that's like it's sort of like
tangential to the story of The Exorcist
kind of like focuses on lieutenant
Herman who was yet of a minor character
in the first one and it's he's like I
almost wanted to do it more like like a
police procedural or like a serial
killer type story yes just with these
characters in it that's only sort of
marginally related yes original it's the
same universe and if you saw X is just
one you will know exactly who it is
they're talking about that that priest
comes back yeah and what's his name
father Karras yeah Father Damien Karras
he's in it it's the same actor all kinds
of [ __ ] it's it's it's about possession
but you know in some ways kind of
reminds me of the same storyline as as
the frighteners where serial killers
coming back and possessing people what
he didn't really possess people did he
yeah no I guess it's ghostly killing
people yeah it's a good movie it's it is
a possession movie but instead of a
demon it's like a serial killer who's I
guess he's getting guess he's kind of
been promoted to demon yeah because he
was he was executed yeah the Gemini
killers anybody's played by Brad Dourif
probably brad dwarfs best role I think
yeah he's kind of like the zodiac yeah
he's based on this OD and he can jump in
and out of people's bodies yeah
especially if there's something mentally
wrong with them leaves I'm open to
possession and then it turns out one of
the guys that he possesses his father
Karras yeah but I don't want to spoil
everything about cuz I don't think this
is a very well appreciated movie in
modern times I don't think a lot yeah
and like I said almost like a brand new
movie and shudders showing it yeah it's
utter and I think if it might be on to
be it's on YouTube if you if you
subscribe to YouTube it's it's in which
you know I have I have that YouTube plus
time yeah it's in one of the free movies
of this month
yeah and it's blu-ray quality it looks
great I think the movie came out what
1990 1990 yeah but it looks it looks
awesome yeah it looks really good and
the just the score the music the sound
effects the special effects that they
used it's um practical effect
but it's just really classy it's just
like the first one it's just like
Exorcist pretty much like I said even
though it's less about I mean demonic
possession is a factor but it's less
about demonic possession as it is about
the serial killer and this yeah and and
the cop who was investigating it kind of
like his whole yeah I guess it's like
him coming to terms with the house
shitty the universes yeah I guess yeah
and he's a cop he's got a real heart you
know George C Scott this [ __ ]
just hard-boiled as [ __ ] okay but very
angry yeah but he's intelligent you know
and he's running across paranormal [ __ ]
sooo paranormal stuff it's just cool
flick you guys see it yeah yeah so why
did it I'm happening like I said William
Peter Blatty he kind of got this idea
he's like well I'm gonna take lieutenant
kinderman who was actually played by Lee
Jay Cobb in the original movie but
obviously he had to be played by George
he's got in this one because Lee Jacob
died only three years after the original
Exorcist came out so some of the
characters from the first movie are in
this but are played by different actors
for whatever reason because the original
actor died or wasn't available or
whatever so I guess that William Peter
Blatty had written a screenplay called
Legion and that he couldn't really get
any interest in it at the time so he
turned it into a novel which came out in
1983 and was like a huge bestseller so
then he was approached by you know the
movie production company it's like well
why don't we make it into a movie and
he's like fine so he readapted it back
into a screenplay but the studio
insisted on calling it Exorcist 3 even
though Exorcist two had tanked and made
the whole Exorcist thing like into a
joke pretty much so he's just like
please don't call it that it's like you
don't want in relation it's like yes
it's in the same universe but basically
it's a standalone movie you don't really
need to have seen the first one it's
gonna yeah appreciate this one although
it gives it more resonance because of
all of the characters are would have
called it something like Legion to
something rather than Exorcist
someone like that yeah he said if you
must call it as he's like watchers call
it Exorcist Legion or something like
that
just please please do not call it
Exorcist 3 yeah however they did they
went ahead and called it tanks to this
movie and did moderately well I didn't
see it it wasn't doing as well it didn't
do as well as they expected and he's you
know William Peter Blatty thought it was
so funny because he's like they came
back to me and then they're like hey the
movie didn't do as well as we expected
must because if exorcist ooh and he's
like dad that's why I told you not to
call it and I'll call it
dumbasses but the thing about it though
okay now it's amazing to me that this
movie works as well as it does
considering that a lot of the [ __ ]
that's in it like in the final
theatrical version was not supposed to
be in there father Karras his character
played by Jason Miller was originally
not supposed to be part was not supposed
to be in the movie because when they
were first thinking about doing the
movie he wasn't available for whatever
reason either cuz he was working on
something else or whatever the reason
was so he wasn't gonna be in the movie
so but then later on he became available
in the studio said oh you should put him
in like to time in like the first movie
so they had to do like all these
rewrites and [ __ ] like that
another thing the studio said was that
well this is called Exorcist 3 because
we decided that that's what it was going
to be called and there's no exorcism in
it because originally that wasn't gonna
happen like it had a totally different
ending so then they had to write in an
exercise exercise they had to write in
an exorcist character yeah father
morning who's played by Nikhil
Williamson who was an Excalibur actually
he played Merlin yeah that's the same
guy so to recognize him yeah so yeah he
looks completely different in those
because he has like blond hair and
everything so it's interesting so if you
I guess if you know that like when you
watch the movie it makes sense but if it
makes sense if you don't know that but
you really really really have to pay
attention to every line of dialogue
everything that I didn't know I didn't
know that that stuff was grafted in
there it didn't really matter the final
product I thought was really cool I
didn't see a job and they they it's not
like what they're doing with the modern
horror movies works like a scare a
second and it's like you know over the
top it's not like that it's kind of like
this kind of like a
seventies movie in a certain way but
ramped up almost kind of like change
like it kind of reminded me of
changeling yeah there is a bunch of
paranormal stuff happening but it sets a
mood first and that's the law that's a
lot of problems with some of the newer
movie newer horror movies that I've seen
they don't really establish a mood or a
tone as a baseline to launch the horror
from yeah and it doesn't wrap up slowly
enough and this one it kind of does I
just liked it the cool thing about this
movie one of the coolest things is that
and I saw another reviewer like point
this out this one more time they said
that you can tell that a writer directed
this because William freaking who
directed the first movie he was
originally supposed to direct this one
as well but then him and William Peter
Blatty kind of had a falling out William
Peter Blatty he actually wanted John
Carpenter to direct this oh you'd have
[ __ ] it up but then maybe yeah I liked
carpenter bejita this is not his yeah
this is not really his kind of material
yeah but then they kind of but John
Carpenter was kind of like well you seem
like you want to direct this William
Peter Blatty
the novelist and he's like you're right
I think I will direct it myself so he
did now I think that the only I think
the only other movie that William Peter
Blatty ever directed was the Knights
configuration which you can see the
parallels because it's all out of the
same actors are in it too you know Scott
Wilson yet and [ __ ] like that was at it
but um what well I was going to say the
difference between this kind of movie in
a new horror movies when you watch a new
more horror movie it's kind of like a
ride at Disneyland it kind of like that
damn haunted house you know it's not
real you know the story is not real you
know that the people telling you the
story know that you know that it isn't
real it's just kind of like an
entertainment thing this one's weird it
it has the tone of something that's
realistic yeah and it slowly starts
ramping it up and it shows kind of shows
you what a ghost can do if a ghost can
possess somebody can it possess you or
can it alter your senses and your view
it's weird you know I mean people having
visions yeah just I liked it yeah show
you the hallucinations that something
that then
it's very grounded in reality but it's
like yeah do like dream sequence II kind
of [ __ ] it's not like soft focus or
anything and then the score behind it
accentuates it like you know Georgie
Scott's seeing horrible [ __ ] and then
boom it's gone he's like whoa where'd it
go
nothing happened you know it wasn't
physical it was an attack on the mind
you know I mean just the way they
portrayed that I thought was pretty cool
yeah but like another one of the cool
things about this one one thing the
score is very very subtle it's not like
you know yeah it's not like that it's
very a lot of times there's no music at
all and I think that makes it creepier
another thing that's really interesting
about this the editing is really weird
and like keeps you like unsettled
because sometimes they'll be like two
characters and they'll be having a
conversation there's like a hard cut
yeah it's so like you suck and it's like
really edit and it just keeps you on
edge throughout the whole movie because
he did that on purpose
there's a couple scenes I think it's at
least one scene where somebody crawls
across the ceiling and you're not sure
if that's something that happened in
reality or if they're [ __ ] with you
you anime yeah because that one woman
crawled across the ceiling and there's a
lot of people in that no notice and no
one noticed it what did that really
happen or is the movie playing with your
mind although it just occurred to me
that if someone was crawling across the
ceiling right now I probably wouldn't
notice it either because I can't see
this you know maybe maybe they're just
kind of artistically tried to you know
kind of express another concept another
idea like maybe astral projection or
something you know maybe the person's
spirit was on the or it's a
hallucination you don't know yeah well
like I said and another interesting
thing about this too I mean other than
the time that they take to build up all
this stuff and you really do actually
care about I mean because George see
Scott is like the main character and you
really kind of like feel his journey and
he's just he's so tired and pissed off
and you know he's just going through all
this anger and grief and [ __ ] like that
with all this stuff that's going on in
the town with all these murders and you
know he's just over it and you know him
in the front is you know the friendship
with father Dyer and stuff like that
which they did a little bit in the orig
like I said with different actors these
things same characters but another thing
they do which i think is a really
interesting choice that makes this
creepier in my opinion and this is
something that I've found with like a
lot of movies that I think are creepy
sometimes not showing stuff is scarier
than showing stuff they do not show
anything in this movie pretty much um
it's like you know what I mean they'll
be like a dead body like for example
like in the opening scene where there's
been a little boy like a twelve-year-old
boy and he's been murdered like in a
really horrible way all they showed they
showed George see Scott lifting up the
sheet and living and being like oh man
[ __ ] yeah and then later he describes
yeah you know what what happened to the
kid yeah and it's worse the description
as was you can imagine you can imagine
it right you don't add a lot of people
get murdered in gruesome ways but they
never show it yeah you don't see it and
in a way to talk about you just see like
the aftermath type of thing like when
one of the characters gets killed and
like all his blood is drained out and
putting little jars and [ __ ] it's like
they just show through the body into the
sheet and the jars and then the cop very
creepily like tells exactly like what
happened and in a way that's like way
creepier to me because you're picturing
it in your head rather than seeing it in
front of it if you if you had seen say a
prosthetic dummy yeah of the victor it
would have taken it would have taken the
impact away it's better just to not see
it they just had it covered with the
damn crime scene cloth or yeah it was
like a sheet or what and all you saw was
like George C Scott's reaction like you
know his his friend like his best friend
gets murdered and it's like he just
comes in he just lifts up the sheet and
you could just see his face like there's
weird dreams is where George C Scott has
a vision where he's in heaven and all
the victims are there with [ __ ] her
heads sewn back on back on and they're
up there with the angels and angels
they're saying thing it's and it's like
you know damn central is in a hospital
or cross between a hospital and grand
yeah it is creepy they like kind of like
a real dream and he's talking to talking
to them in a dream like that murdered
yes are you got murdered
it's just like just in a really nice
yeah in a way yeah it's weird it's a
great flick it's weird it makes a lot of
sense it has some fantastic acting in it
they act the [ __ ] out of this movie
particular songs between I mean I
haven't even got into like the plot is a
little bit complicated like again
you know George C Scott who plays
kinderman there's been this is basically
set I think it's either 15 years or 17
years I can't remember after the events
of the original Exorcist now there's
been a serial killer there was a serial
killer called the Gemini who was
executed for a series of crimes like 15
years before however there has been a
new series of murders that seem very
much like the Gemini killings and even
like two details that weren't released
to the public so there was no way that
somebody could be copycatting because
they released like fake details to the
press and whatever like to screen out
you know cranks and whatnot so it turns
out that analogous to when these murders
started occurring again like with the
little boy and like all these beheadings
and like all this really weird [ __ ]
there also was this guy who had wandered
into like the hospital or whatever and
he couldn't remember anything and he was
comatose for 15 years but suddenly woke
up when all these murders started going
on now when George C Scott's kinderman
character goes to visit him he discovers
that it's father Karras who died spoiler
alert yeah who died at the end of the
first movie so then like this whole
thing you know transpires that like the
demon from the first movie is like
possessing and like he wants to bring
the Gemini killer back and all this
other kind of stuff so it's like yeah so
it it's all this kind of stuff so there
is possession in it but I would call it
more it's kind of hard to classify it's
more like a police procedural but it's
got a lot of supernatural and religion
yeah it's not quite as dry as as kind of
an average police pursue yeah 70s when
those movies were big it's it's it's
it's better well actually there was a
lot of police procedural type horror
movies in the 90s - that's true yeah
what Evan and all that right this
reminds me very much of 7 yeah
um I I feel that was a pretty good one I
feel like seven probably took a lot from
this because I just watched seven again
recently and it did occur to me how
similar these team even though seven
doesn't have a supernatural element but
I don't know just the way it progresses
the way the story progresses reminded me
seven like a little more colorful I
think and the score was a lot more
over-the-top and stuff this one is very
like I said was very much Peter Olin but
it's that makes it creepy and yeah I
mean they'll be like it's the same tone
as Exorcist one yes that same tone same
way have you watch them both together it
seems like because I mean they'll be
like great scenes where like you know
kinderman is in the office like talking
to the priest or whatever and they're
just talking there's no score there's no
nothing you know there's all that's all
that's in the background it's like a
clock ticking all of a sudden the clock
stops yeah and then they just turn
toward it and then all of a sudden like
a door creaks open yeah the paper blows
a lot of silence which you know yeah
it's really really creepy and it's just
like there's just such great [ __ ]
scenes in this I mean the whole [ __ ] at
the end with um with the woman that
escapes from the thing and like dresses
like a nurse and like goes the house and
that's all super creepy like with her
just sitting in the cab like going to
thank and all this other stuff and we
have to talk to about the very very
famous which is probably the most famous
thing about this movie and which some
people have called the best jump scare
in horror movie history which is the
scene in that long scene of the hallway
with the thing coming out with like the
white thing over it we like the big yeah
don't ruin it don't ruin no just a lot
of people have seen that even the ones
that happens they know about what but
one thing that's really cool about that
scene is the way you would never well I
don't want to say like nowadays they
would never do a scene like that because
like I said there's a lot more arthouse
horror and stuff like that but the way
that scene is set up is genius it goes
on for like ten minutes you know what I
mean it's like and it's just this long
like a long shot and you feel like
nothing's gonna happen like what the
[ __ ] is going on why are we at the end
of this hallway and like all these
people are [ __ ] around down there
like in the hospital and everything and
then you know oh there's a noise and the
nurse comes in there and then there's a
fake jump scare and they're just like
all this other and then it's like just
goes on and on and on
like nothing's gonna happen man and then
BAM and it's like it's so so effective
yeah it's weird and I'm not usually like
a big jump-scare type of person but that
one was like really really yeah
masterfully done but this is um you know
like I said this I think it's for free
on to be and you said it's like for free
on YouTube okay it's not free for
YouTube you check but I think it's
because I subscribed yeah it's also on
shudder yeah now like I said there's
very famously there's a director's cut
of this because after all the studio
interference I guess we're just so we
have to put Jason Miller in it oh we
have to put an exorcism in it which was
kind of like the big set piece at the
end like this big exorcism which wasn't
in the original script and I guess
William Peter Blatty was kind of like
pissed off about it and even Brad Dourif
who was in the movie who plays Gemini um
he didn't really like how the movie came
out because he's like you know that's
not anything like what the original
vision of the movie was but you know a
lot of the footage got lost over the
years what shout factory ended up doing
I think when they put out the blu-ray
fairly recently was they were able to
find they said we couldn't find anything
like quality like of the first you know
cut of the film because they cut the
film together and then the production
company said hey we need that we need an
exorcism hey we need to put Jason Miller
in it so William Peter Blatty had to go
back and insert a bunch of [ __ ] you know
what I mean like after it was already
done so Shou factory has both versions
of it on they have both versions but the
problem is like I said a lot of the
footage that was shot that was cut out
like to put the new [ __ ] in was lost but
they did find like old videotapes of
like the dailies so they did kind of
cobble it back together they said from
the best available sources so some of
its not that great but I should say that
I saw the original ending like that
William Pete that was in the script and
everything like that and I hate to say
it but I think the studio ending was
yetter most people say the theatrical
version is is better is better um you
know I can see what because it's more
movie like it's like what you expect of
a movie and I think that I think the
directors version of
is more like something could come from a
book yeah I mean you know the the
director's cut even I mean the
theatrical cut is very similar to the
book but I mean the director's cut was
almost exactly like the book and it
ended like the book which that's fine
you know in the book that ending was
perfectly fine but I do feel like
theatres different yeah I feel like the
ending the director's cut ending was a
little anticlimactic yeah this ends in a
big grand finale big paranormal grand
finale and that's where it should it
ended yes so in a way I think like even
though yes the studio is metaled and yes
he had again he was pissed off and he
had to go back and add this other stuff
had a satisfying end it did actually
have like build up to a satisfying
ending so I think they were right about
that and even though like I said Jason
Miller who played Damien Karras he
wasn't in the original cut of the film
they put him in later like after he
became available so they had to like
write him in and sew him and Brad Dourif
for like changing out anyway kind of but
in a way I kind of like that because
you're seeing him as like a difference
he's like a demon like he's got like a
bunch of phases and yeah he assumes
different phases and I didn't know that
was something that was added later it
made perfect sense when I watched yeah
it's like if I didn't find out no I
wouldn't find out until later that that
was cobbled together it was [ __ ]
awesome yeah you would never know that
yeah you see you see Father Damien there
and then he gets possessed and then you
see the other guy talking yeah the
killer you see the Gemini right he and
that's that's perfectly fine for a movie
like this and like I said that's what I
mean it's like the whole premise is that
he's possessed by a demon right and that
dude acted his ass off - what's his name
again Brad Dourif Brad Dourif child's
play yeah you said the voice of dune he
played one of the men she does a great
job he looks [ __ ] insane in this he
knows plays crazy like Brad yeah and
it's like it makes me sad that I mean
because the scenes with him and George
see Scott in the cell because there's
like a lot of really long scenes edited
out you can that are almost like a stage
play where it's just like the two of
them like talking and stuff and like
they have these big long conversations
and he has these really long creepy
Brants where he's like talking about all
the [ __ ] that he did to the victim
freezing as he should and it's just so
[ __ ] great in this and it's just it
makes me sad that he didn't get some
kind of award or something like that it
also kind of makes me sad that he wished
that the direct they had kept the
director's cut they should have [ __ ]
kept that name Legion it would it would
have been a great standalone and if and
if you and everyone who would who would
have went to go see this movie would
know that this is Exorcist yeah this is
they would know you don't you have to
announce it that's when I figure out
like I guess you nowadays
it's they they're not so weird about
that like cuz that they'll call a movie
like something else and then everyone
will just find out that that's the
sequel they should have done that I
agree with William Peter Blatty
I don't think that the acting and it's
great it really is like an Academy Award
winning acting best [ __ ] about the
students one of the most surprising
things particularly on you know George C
Scott's character him it kinderman 's
interactions with father Dyer like his
best friend like their movie buddies and
they hang out they've been friends a
long time like the dialogue between them
is so [ __ ] great like it's really
funny this is like a a weirdly funny
movie yeah okay no no let's let's kind
of put this into context this this is a
really good movie
I think this technically is better than
Exorcist one is actually you would not
be the first person to say yeah I think
it is although The Exorcist is a [ __ ]
masterpiece and it's a reset saat own
that's hard to beat yeah but you could
watch those two movies back to back and
you just go yeah this is this is the
[ __ ] Exorcist this just [ __ ]
bad-ass yeah you know this is a good
movie and and it's just is it better
than the Exorcist yeah I think probably
technically it is I bet it is the art of
seventies movie is yeah that 70s classic
movie it comes ruin it better I was
watching a review today by a guy and he
liked this one better than the original
Exorcist I don't know if I are
diplomatic
it is like it is like saying everybody
loves the [ __ ]
um The Shining yeah dr. sleep was pretty
damn good too
yeah technically I probably say this
might be a little bit better movie but
that Kubrick is really hard to beat
yeah tone that he sets that you know I
mean he's doing it he's making an
original there yeah I think it might be
a situation like that it is kind of
because I feel like you know and I know
this is kind of a cop-out but it's kind
of like hard to say because and in a way
you have to really admire I mean yes
we'll forget that Exorcist who the
heretic existed because I think
everybody in their bother thinks this is
terrible but I loved that they were like
okay well we're gonna make a sequel you
know William Peter Blatty was like we're
gonna make us think we're just gonna
pretend that piece of [ __ ] didn't exist
I'm just gonna make a direct sequel that
happens like 15 17 years later and it's
like he didn't do it's not it's a horror
movie kind of but it's more like a
psychological thriller doing the thing
and it's like he just kind of took that
universe and went a completely different
direction with it which I thought was
kind of cool with some nods to the
original one like like I said it's the
same universe there's demons and stuff
like this is one of the best satanic
movies yeah talking about it's up there
with Exorcist oh man yeah oh man one
this one and then you got oh man you
know two and three you know it's in
those riots and then like man I almost
said a medieval [ __ ]
but revisiting Amityville Horror that
was pretty bad it's not as good as I
remember I've never liked it but it's
not as good there were certain episodes
oh that's [ __ ] there are certain
episodes of the haunting that are better
than the better than [ __ ] although I
like the acting in Amityville war it had
a good tone but this is right there with
them and like I said this one else
towards the top of that pile that I just
described you know I mean there's and
shining I'll put that in there this
number is a satanic movie but yeah this
is a strong movie
I'm sorry surprised it's just like it's
really cool because like I said you can
tell that a writer directed this it's
filmic but it's also
literary you know what I mean and it's
like it's it's really hard to explain
and if you've seen his other movie the
ninth configuration you'll know what I'm
talking about
it's kind of like Jean Wyllys because he
because the ninth configuration was like
that - I don't see now um it you know
where it's just like it's a weird and
you're if somebody said what genre is
this or what's it about it's like kind
of hard to pin it down also like I said
the way that the shots are composed the
blocking the editing it's like just very
strange but in a way that really kind of
contributes to the overall atmosphere of
the movie I mean the way that the way
that Exorcist 3 is edited it just keeps
you it's it makes you nervous like the
whole time because you're not entirely
sure you don't know what's going on
because you see that just just one so
that's part that's another thing
Exorcist one is a different story yeah
this is related to that story but it is
a very different story if Exorcist one
is better part of it is because of the
nature of the story this yeah but in
terms of quality in direction and acting
and everything man that's it this is my
dad er it's so really close it's really
creamy like the whole atmosphere of it
it's just really unsettling had I known
how to watched it a long time ago I
gotta get on blu-ray Exorcist yeah and
this one on blue I want to get that I
don't ever want to get that Xiao Feng
I'm kind of curious to see the
directions like I said I've seen the end
like how it ended in the director's cut
and honestly I think the theatrical cut
is a much better ending like it's a lot
more satisfying I guess because it was
kind of like a bigger splash because I
you know it's like I'm not one of those
people that's like oh I need a big
explosions or anything like yeah not
that then you go into this don't think
of X is just one this is a movie more
like seven it's a police movie yeah but
if you liked Exorcist 1 it's all gonna
start coming back to you and like you
said it good it has like a lot of
similarities with Exorcist one in the
pacing and your tone and things like
because Exorcist 1 was pretty slow
moving in the audio and the visual
effects those creepy [ __ ]
sound effects that you know and the
flashes and [ __ ] and edits it was weird
yeah and like just like exercise 1d
noises yeah it didn't use a lot of jump
scares or anything like that maybe had
one or something like that
this one's same type of thing it has one
but it's a [ __ ] doozy other than that
it's just used like really unsettling
imagery it it let you use your
imagination to come up with [ __ ] because
like I said there just be somebody like
describing something it does end with an
exorcism
it's a different nature of exorcism
indeed like you don't see you know
Amanda from Exorcist one those those are
iconic scenes that yeah they they made
the correct decision of not trying to
copy that yeah they did it in a
different way it was more about visions
yeah that had a lot to do with it and
mind control yeah
which that was the way to go and it had
a real satisfying ending that's all I'm
gonna say about this movie there's no
way I forgot to mention with when you
said about visions and it reminded her
there's a lot of like really weird
cameos and this yeah in the vision thing
like in heaven and stuff there's Fabio
yes also samuel l.jackson was in there
although he was hard to tell who he was
because they just showed him quick and
they dubbed his voiceover Fabio plane to
a angel he pulled that [ __ ] off too
he did like with his face yeah um also C
everett Koop who was the Surgeon General
he was in the [ __ ] Larry King was in
there like no restauranteurs and [ __ ]
like that all star cast this was should
have been a blockbuster movie it should
have been had they [ __ ] called it
Legion it would have been it would have
been well because like I said boom in
1990 people were getting kind of used to
this
ya honor because in the 70s Exorcist 1
was was was groundbreaking and yeah and
very obscene it was very shocking for
the time yeah I mean even still that
crucifix masturbation scene I mean
that's still a little bit hmm robbed
space right but you can see that kind of
[ __ ] nowadays you know in those days can
you imagine seeing that in 1973 yeah
it's 73 in an expensive well-made movie
whereas with with Max von Sydow in it
and like you know real Hollywood name
they kicked ass on that movie that that
that movie caused the satanic panic if
you ask me well it was one of them that
was Mary's baby I went Rosen apparently
a few years because all of a sudden
people said oh [ __ ] that's possible yeah
but like you said the sad thing about it
is that the novel that this movie was
based on was called Legion and it was a
best-selling novel so why didn't they
just say well it's an adaptation of that
oh and by the way it's also you know
it's kind of a sequel to The Exorcist
like I said yeah it's a sequel in the
sense that happens after shout factory
should have rereleased it cleaned it up
give it a different poster and called it
legion yeah and then in the final
summary we'll just call it that and then
in the fine print called it that's what
it was supposed to be called if you see
like all the [ __ ] like even I've seen
like screenshots from the director's cut
that's what it's called it was just
called Legion it's called Legion you
know they're not spoiler alert it's
called Legion because when this killer
comes back as a ghost in and he's
possessing people he's making references
to all kinds of other demonic forces and
people that are helping him yeah and the
existence you know the hierarchy behind
him and stuff there is a legion of them
yeah well it comes right out of the bite
out of the vibe like right out or Jesus
that's not just like yeah it's know
what's your name I am Legion yes it's
not a lone soul kind of like it was in
frighteners yeah you know it's he's a
representative of a [ __ ] greater army
yeah it's wild it's wow yeah like I said
this is definitely one it's like a
really creepy unsettling kind of movie
and it's one that you really need to pay
attention to like all the dialogue and
so because it's all it's cool the story
is kind of complicated yeah you know
what I mean and like I said it's an
old-school added a bunch of spoiler so
if you pay attention like you know
you'll kind of get all the gist and it
has like some really really great like
creepy image yeah I want to see it again
yeah we won't watch it again if you want
to I mean you know I want to see it
again I feel like it's a little
underappreciated so if you haven't seen
it you definitely should and it's all
over the place very easy to get hold of
the showing are free right now yep
Exorcist 3 otherwise known as Legion
so go check